we also use retrospective facial
recognition through the home office
provision of the police National
Database at the moment although in the
met we are actually procuring our own
system
nationally there's a third use of facial
recognition which I think is probably
worth mentioning at this point and
that's what we call officer initiated
facial recognition and that's somewhere
between retrospective which is the
historical use and live and it's where
an officer in the street has access to a
mobile phone and they'll take a picture
of the suspect and it will immediately
then compare that picture to a watch
list of images
in each of these cases is it right to
say that there's a common denominator
which is a watch list in other words
you've got a list of
not just people but their their faces
images of them that it's checking
against so it's not an abstract picture
derived by artificial intelligence of as
it were someone likely to commit crime
it's a specific individual that is
uploaded that it's looking for is that
exasperated right in all those three use
cases it's comparity and comparison
against a watch list
and could you tell me how that watch
list is compiled so I'm going to take
live facial recognition because it is
actually different between those three
three different techniques I just
described to you so in live facial
recognition the watch list is bespoke
and specific to the deployment and it's
generated by looking at the intelligence
case so essentially the reason why we're
using the technology in the first place
the watch list is then compiled based on
crime types based on people likely to be
in the area at that time who are wanted
whether wanted for service offenses
wanted on court warrants and then after
that deployment is complete that watch
list is deleted so it's very much a
bespoke watch list for the deployment
location at that point in time for
example if you take the coronation and
it was specific and bespoke to that
event and contains some fixated
individuals who we knew were going to go
to the coronation and potentially do
harm I see and just in terms of the the
artificial intelligence dimension of
this first of all in terms of the
technology did you design it yourself
did you write just write it yourself or
is it procured no absolutely not it's
procured and
see that's that information is is
publicly available on our website
NEC manufacture all different types of
facial recognition technology and that's
the algorithm that we're using okay and
just say a little about you know what so
what is the artificial intelligence
in this facial recognition technology
involves essentially biometric matching
and Dr Mansfield will be able to explain
the AI in probably much better detail
than I can but the AI element of that as
well is where the algorithm is doing
that biometric matching so essentially
it's looking at the watch list looking
at each image and taking a set of
measurements of the face that's the
biometric bit and it's comparing it to
the measurements of the face of the
image that the cameras then pick up does
it differ in any material respect from
the e-passport gates where you put your
passport in and the camera recognizes
whether you are the person on the
passport it's not NEC technology I don't
think e-passport Gates and I don't know
enough about what they're using to to be
able to answer that behind it is facial
recognition technology just briefly
documentary because we'll come into more
detail on it but are we talking about
the same sort of thing even though they
might be manufactured by different
people
he he Gates the face recognition is the
same sort of thing it's manufactured by
different companies developed by
different companies and the the AI
component is
um the the AI techniques are used in
order to extract the the best features
for making face comparisons and that's
left left to to artificial intelligence
to develop that rather than being kind
of a predefined model so it's a it's a
Step Beyond the e-gates thing that is
looking for fixed parameters it's more
exploratory as to what's right the
e-gate system and the NEC systems are
probably have a fair amount of neural
neural networks artificial intelligence
in their development processes they do
too so actually some of what we're
talking about
in the police context actually might
have an application for border security
in particular passport control as well
potentially yes and the other thing I
should say about the live facial
recognition algorithms we used is it's
it's a closed Network
so by that I mean there's computers in
advance put this really simplistically
and there's cameras on the van and that
Loop is closed so it's not linked up to
other cameras
um and neither is it retaining the
information and learning from every face
that goes in front of it that's not
happening okay so so just specifically
on that before I turn to to my
colleagues so it's not that every CCTV
camera across London is as it were sort
of primed to look for a person on the
watch list you've set up a camera in a
place that you suspect that
person might be frequenting and it's
that camera and that camera alone rather
than as it were sort of remote ones
being accessed absolutely it's it's
limited to the cameras which are
specific to that deployment based on a
specific intelligence case which is
relevant to the area we're in so for
example we deployed it recently in
Camden in Camden we know that being
significant amounts of gang crime and
knife-enabled robbery and there was also
your core earlier in January the
shooting around Houston again gaming
Affiliated
um that seemed to be a good location
there was a strong intelligence case so
we set up cameras in a closed loop back
to the van with a specific watch list
for that deployment I see
so that's how it's done at the moment
but in principle could
the the network of cameras across the
country across the capital be linked to
that watch list so that they could not
be a closed loop in the way that you
describe it but it could be a general
thing is it is it a an operational or a
policy decision you've made to restrict
it or is it is it a different
is it technically impossible to do the
broader things technically I
swear governed by the law and currently
we're operating under the common law
primarily and then a patchwork of other
legislation underneath it and various
codes of practice and other information
from from regulators and advice that
we're following as well so under that
and learning an awful lot from the
bridges judgment and the bridges appeal
at the moment there must be a solid use
case why would applying the technology
we need to understand the questions
brought up in bridges which is around
where we deploying it and why and what's
the proportionality and necessity of
that and who is on the watch list and
again why and the proportionality and
necessity of that I think my colleagues
were going to some detail on that case
the subject of our inquiry the purpose
of our inquiry is the future governance
of AI so these questions of what what
might be possible are equally as as of
Interest as what is currently being done
so thank you for that I'm going to turn
to my colleagues now starting with Dawn
Butler and then Graeme street thank you
chair um thank you both for coming in
today um
just want to pick up on some of the
responses to the chair just now in
regards to
the the data that you collect you said
it's a closed loop so big brother watch
has been doing a lot of work around this
so can we confirm that all of the data
that you collect say at the coronation
of live facial recognition that all of
that data has been deleted
so we don't collect data actually on a
live facial recognition deployment if
you're imagining you're in the crowd and
you walk past the camera
instantaneously will compare the faces
it sees to the watch list
it's literally instantaneous if you're
not on that watch list not only is your
facial image immediately
and forever deleted but also it's
pixelated and this is what we call a
privacy by Design function which means
if you're an officer sitting in the band
looking at that succession of people
coming past the canvas you can't even
see the individual faces they're all
pixelated the only exception to that is
if we get a hit a positive match in
which case the match can be retained for
31 days
or longer if it's needed for judicial
purposes okay so in regards to if you
get a match
um is it not correct that 81 of people
flagged by live facial recognition were
in fact innocent
I don't recognize those figures I know
the first figures keep popping up and
maybe it's something we can talk about
when we come onto the national physical
laboratory report and what we found out
about the accuracy of the algorithm but
as an example at the coronation
there were two positive matches and that
to me shows the Precision of that
technology and they were both like how
many Force matches were there because so
that is that is the issue isn't it
because in in uh January
2022 the Met deployed elefane Oxford
Circus and one person was triggered
on the alert they were subsequently
stopped
they weren't the person they were
innocent they provided ID
to show they were not the person on the
watch list
but then they were subjected to further
scrutiny and biometric tests before they
were allowed to let go
so does that not
does that not imply that you're
therefore assuming that people are
guilty rather than innocent why did that
person have to provide further
information because
the live facial recognition was
incorrect
I don't unfortunately have details of
that specific incident with me but I'm
very happy to provide further details on
it later
um does Dr Mansfield are you familiar
with that particular incident
you're not okay that's right it's
does it worry you though does it worry
you that there's an over-reliance on a
system that is 81 incorrect so much so
that if somebody is stopped and says
well I'm I'm not that person you know
it's like we'll prove it to us again the
two two ways I want to answer that first
of all I can look back at the last six
deployments we've done and I can tell
you of those six deployments we have had
two three four true alerts and zero
false alerts I'll need to go back to
your 2022 example but that's as an
example of just how precise the
technology is it's not flagging alerts
all the time how do you measure it how
when you say zero Force alerts it's only
because you're only counting your
positive alerts so what does that mean
that what does that mean exactly I think
we we count true alerts and we count
false alerts and we test the system
throughout a deployment by having what
we call a blue list which are our
members of staff and officers who are on
a separate watch list who walk past
through the system every I think 40 40
minutes or so to check that it's working
accurately and it's not simply just not
detecting anybody
um the other thing I said answer in two
ways that the second answer to what
you're saying is what happened when
another happens what what does the
officer do so the facial recognition of
Technology only takes you so far it
takes you to the point of a potential
identification that's all and it will
show the watchlist this picture and it
will show you the picture of the
individual who's a potential
identification on the mobile phone
device that the office the police
officer yeah
to the police officer
um and they'll look at that and that's
when their normal officer Powers kick in
and they'll look at it and they'll think
is that a match is that a likely match
if they don't think it's a match they
don't need to do anything
they're not compelled to make the stop
but that's on paper if they think it's a
match there's no immediate arrest
they'll go and talk to that person and
have an engagement that's similar to any
day-to-day activity of a police officer
who acts usually on suspicion at this
point they're having a tool a very
accurate tour to point them in the right
direction so then all the other activity
you saw subsequent to that
um is standard officer engagement
standard officer engagement in regards
for instance to stop and search is
disproportionately discriminated against
young black men
um and in all cases and the Met being
one of the highest 80 of the times
nothing's found so if you're building a
system based on a ready discriminatory
system then you're making that
discrimination worse
can I ask you another question uh do we
have a democratic demographic breakdown
of the watch list that the Met currently
hold
so no we don't and that's because we
don't go after individuals on the watch
list we don't say let's take that named
person and put them on the watch list
the watch list is made up of crime types
so the demographic balance of that is it
is is it's not something that's
considered it's the crime types it's the
wanted people in the area at the time
and immediately afterwards as I was
saying that watch list is is deleted can
we get a demographic breakdown of the
watch list
we haven't done that because there's no
policing purpose to retain and then
process that information for that reason
if you have a watch list that's uh 90
women
it would mean that you're looking for
women in a crowd because that's that's
on your what if if a woman Flags out
you'll be like oh right okay that woman
is the person that's on our watch list
there's more of a match there so there
is a correlation between the demographic
breakdown of the watch list and what you
do with that information so is it
possible to get a breakdown first of all
we'd never put a watch to this together
which was 90 any demographic
differential
but if you don't measure it how do you
know it's not how it's done it's based
on crime types people who are wanted for
robbery offenses in the area people who
are wanted on court warrants and there's
a breakdown and a list of the types of
offenses the types of reasons to be
included in the watch list on our policy
so that's that's available and open to
the public so we we wouldn't go after a
specific demographic that that wouldn't
be right would you provide the committee
with a breakdown so I can't because we
delete the watch list within 24 hours
immediately after the deployment and
there isn't a policing purpose to
process the data in that way
ethnically you say you delete the watch
list yes so you haven't got a watch list
the Met hasn't got a watch list so the
watch list is bespoke to the individual
deployment so each live facial
recognition deployment we do we create a
very bespoke watch list of crime types
which mirror the the reason for being in
that area in the first place we then at
the end of the deployment delete that
watch list which was bespoke to the
deployment and then if we were going to
deploy again somewhere else for a
different reason we'd create a different
watch list of different crime types
so there's no way at any time of getting
a breakdown and and you only have a
watch list a temporary watch list
there's never a permanent watch list
it's not a permanent watch list for live
facial recognition technology for every
deployment it's based on an individual
intelligence case which is the reason
why it's both proportionate and
necessary for us to be in that area
operating at the time that watch list is
then bespoke to the deployment we use it
and then we delete it because there's no
there's no lawful reason for us to
retain that data
technically we could do it
keep the watch list but lawfully we
can't we delete it each time because
there's no there's no policing reason to
process data purely to find out
demographic difference within a watch
list do you see any risks at all with uh
live facial recognition or other facial
recognitions or Ai and its deployment in
the met I completely understand public
concern around life facial recognition
technology and Ai and there's lots of
debate going on around that at the
moment what I've tried to do with the
introduction of facial recognition
technology in the Met is do so in a
careful proportionate and as transparent
as we possibly can be way so we've
published an awful lot of information
online about how we operate about
exactly some of the things we were just
talking about about the distinctions of
who can and can't be on a watch list and
all of the safeguards we've put in place
in order to to to protect people what
risks have you identified
gosh um I I think
we can run through the risks and and the
safeguards we've put in place at every
single stage of the operation so
starting right at the beginning
um I talked about necessity and
proportionality of why you were going
there in the first place this isn't the
fishing Expedition we're targeting areas
where there's public concern about high
levels of crime whether that's
it's a knife enabled thefts on Oxford
Street where we operated before or
whether it was some of the gang-related
violence and also knife-enabled robbery
going on in Camden so there's some
examples of specific use cases
carrying that through from why you were
there in the first place there's then
the proportionality of the watch list
following our policy as to who goes on
there and why and then on the day of
deployment we have safeguards in place
there so we won't run the deployment if
um there's something wrong with the
technology the images that I accepted
into watch lists need to be of a certain
quality the cameras need to be operating
in a certain way to make sure they're
also as accurate as we can make them
um throughout the deployment there's
particular special training given to
officers who are going to deploy on the
ground which causes of your concerns
sorry just one last
um
does the training include
further intrusion if somebody innocent
has been identified and my last question
is does it concern you in any way that
the Metropolitan Police
is currently institutionally racist
homophobic and misogynistic and
and how that
will affect the use of this technology
um can I deal with institutional racism
first and then I'll come back to the
further intrusion because I'm not sure
if I understood that
um you're referring to baroness Casey's
report and other incidents and it's
truly shocking what's in that report and
we have let the public and our own
people down
um I was shocked at some of the findings
I at the same time see it as an
opportunity for reform
um I think we must turn things around
and I hope the very careful way we've
been approaching the deployment of Life
facial recognition technology is just
that so some of the work we've done with
the national physical laboratory in
order to really get to the heart of the
bias in that technology and understand
how we can use AI but use it in a
proportionate fair and equal way has
been hugely important to me
that's why we publish what we can online
in order to be as transparent as we can
and then before we deploy we do an awful
lot of Engagement so we engage not only
with Commissioners with civil society
with various groups we also engage with
different Community groups and different
demographic differentials across the
piece to understand their feelings about
the technology and then before we
actually go to a location to deploy we
do something called a community impact
assessment where we go out and talk to
members of the community about how they
feel about having live facial
recognition deployed there is it is it
not the case that there was one person
who I think big brother watch held up a
sign saying the police are operating
live facial recognition they avoided uh
where the police were and then they got
a 90 pounds fine because they covered
their face
I knew that was then assumed that they
had something to hide whereas they just
didn't want
to be on the police camera which which
we police by consent in this country so
if you don't want the police to take an
image of your face which is like a
fingerprint then that's
we're policed by consent that's your
choice we do police by consent and at
any live facial recognition deployment
and those who want to are very welcome
to come out and see one actually in
operation we put
um notices up to tell the public that
live facial recognition is by the time
they get to the notice they're already
their faces have already been in the
system because by the time you get to
the notice the camera's already taken so
facial picture of them sorry too no it's
an important area but Mr answer that but
so um we the placement of the signage is
prior to getting onto the vision of the
camera the view of the camera is
actually quite short and again if you
want to come out and have a look you can
see you can see the sort of zone of
recognition and how far that goes along
the road
um and we also depending on the
deployment and what we're seeking to do
published on social media what we're
going to be doing so it is foreseeable
to the public we don't force people to
walk through the cameras I've been on
the scene and many people have turned
around decided not to walk through the
cameras that's absolutely fine but it is
used as part of a Widing wider policing
operation usually there will be police's
officers on the ground and if they make
a informed choice to stop an individual
that's a policing decision okay thank
you let's um take some more colleagues
starting with graham Stringer and
Rebecca Long Bailey
just a couple of questions to to follow
Lindsay one
you
said there you made reassuring
statements about the pixelation and
removing
um
well not retaining the images
can you show that is it audited or
checked by any external body
um
so I can show it to anybody who wants to
come and have a look at it in terms of
if if if you're thinking about who who
oversees Us and how are they over
oversight mechanisms work again it's a
quite a complex Patchwork
um directly we have Mopac Mez office for
policing and crime who have a seat at my
strategic facial recognition board that
I run within the met and stepping out a
little bit more broadly for Mopac
there's the information Commissioner's
Office there's the Biometrics and
surveillance camera commissioner and
we've just started some engagement with
the equality and Human Rights Commission
as well
but does anybody
go in and check
what you're saying about the technology
is is accurate
yes
I mean that was the basis of
mission to the National physical
laboratory to do the testing and we
requested National physical laboratory
to do testing to look at how accurate
the technology was and also to
understand better levels of bias within
the algorithm
okay come on to that in a second
uh can you show operational benefits
absolutely we've had a number of
significant arrests as a result of
facial recognition technology including
conspiracy to supply class A drugs
assault on emergency workers possession
with intensive Supply class A drugs
Grievous bodily harm and being
unlawfully at large having escaped from
prison there's some of the examples that
I've brought here today
but there's more benefit than just the
number of arrests the technology
um alerts police officers to carry out
there's much wider benefit the
coronation is one example of where
deterrence was a benefit you'll have
noticed we've publicized quite widely in
advance that we were going to be there
as part of that deterrence effect
um and then if I recall my time up in
Camden when I went to view one of the
facial recognition deployments there's a
wider benefit to the community in that
area at the time and actually we got
quite a lot of very positive reaction
from shopkeepers and local people
because of the impact it was having on
crime in that area and when we use
facial recognition technology usually it
will be part of a much wider policing
operation so there'll be other stuff
happening in the area as well both some
things you might see some things you
might not see
I realize this is
the the answer is difficult but to you
arrest people all the time can you show
the an increase in rest arrests again
and convictions against a baseline so I
don't think an increase in rests is
really what this tool is about this tool
is a precision-based community crime
writing tool so if you imagine I'm going
to use a terrible analogy of the needle
in the haze but this is the technology
enablers us to pick out a potential
match of someone that's wanted usually
for very serious crimes
um and have the opportunity to go and
speak to that person the results that I
just read out to you are people who
would still be at large if we hadn't
used that technology
um so it's it's not a mass it's not a
tool for Mass arrests it's not a tool
which is going to give you huge numbers
of arrests it's a tool that is very
precisely going to focus on individuals
that we're trying to identify I do
understand that but
and I realized that giving an accurate
detailed answer will be difficult
but it is arresting those wanted people
and
charging them hopefully convicting them
if they're guilty against what otherwise
would have happened and I realize it's a
difficult question to answer but it's
important that you can't
show that there is an improvement along
those lines when so far as those wanted
individuals are pretty bad crimes are no
longer on the streets yes
we are doing more work to look at how
else we might be able to evaluate the
benefits of the technology bear in mind
we're at the quite early stages still of
what has been quite quite a sort of a
careful Journey yeah repeating so that's
Quantified and you have those figures
now I have I figured in front of me
about the number of arrests that I've
been made it takes time for them to work
through the judicial system so arrests
that have been made this year which is
what I have in front of me won't won't
have come through
give the community again in due course
yeah
something is there on arrest this year
yes
yes deployed
um we've deployed Vans six times we've
done three deployments Camden and
Islington and then there are three vans
out during the coronation so that's
three different deployments
um there were one two three four true
alerts
um there were zero Force false alerts
throughout those
um six deployments and there have been
two arrests made
um and the others were correct
identifications but it was decided
arrest was not a necessary action in
those answers
worry about bias in the
um in the learning of AI
built into the system could you
reassure the committee or not uh that
there isn't bias in
uh the system that the greater the
Metropolitan Police are using
me
we were contracted to perform an
evaluation of the
um the
graphic recognition oh the face
recognition algorithm which is being
used in life facial recognition and also
in the other applications that Lindsay
mentioned
um and the the the scope of the study
was to look at to look at performance
performance in terms of accuracy and
performance in terms of the differences
in accuracy for different
for different demographics by different
demographics
um and in doing that we we were
we were running a
an evaluation using a set of of
uh test subjects recruited test subjects
recruited specifically for the
evaluation in addition to data which is
provided by met police to provide a
large
um a large reference data set or article
a large watch list
I hesitate to call you to watch this
because it's far larger than would
normally be on the watch list but a
large amount of data that's allowed us
to to look at the the differences in
performance on a demographic by
demographic basis
our our findings on the on the
the performance on the the demographics
um taking the findings on performance we
found that the system to be
very accurate in some of some of the
applications the retrospective face
recognition and the officer initiated
face recognition the the system was
delivering if you like perfect
performance it was getting 100
um
accuracy so in that in for those for
those applications the
when when the errors the no errors for
any part of the any demographic that's
not sure that's not showing any bias at
all for the live facial recognition
which is a slightly harder task for
facial recognition
recognition
um there was
um non-detection rate so it was about it
was about 90 of people were being
recognized and it was fairly constant
across the different demographics
we did observe
a difference in a difference in
performance between between Graphics but
the but the observations which we had in
terms of the recognition rate were not
um
statistically they're not inconsistent
with with a hypothesis that there was no
difference at all in performance so so
um
if you're running an experiment and
there is a certain chance of being
falsely identified or or falsely not
identified
um
you have you could have a null
hypothesis to say there is no difference
between demographic and the results
which we had the observations we had
were not inconsistent with not
inconsistent with a hypothesis that
there was not a difference
having said that we did observe that
there was
um there was some difference I think
that they um as I recall the asian
females were the with the best
performing had the best recognition rate
and
females of the of the of demographics
had had the lowest but they were but the
values were really quite close
um so we can't
I mean you could you could kind of never
show that there is that there is no bias
because inevitably when you run it when
you run a test if you're tossing coins
I'd just say oh are these Fair coins
You'll Always Find that that
if you toss a coin a lot of times it's
not so if it's a thousand times it's
gonna be 500 heads and 500 tales for for
for a biascoin so there's always going
to be a small amount of
um and
um so when we when we when we looked at
that we
in terms of the other the other type of
error rate
so this is people being falsely
identified
um we observe that at
um
at threshold setting so that so that the
the
face recognition systems
um have a controllable parameter and as
you change that controllable parameter
it it makes it
um the amount of
the amount of evidence that is the same
face it it requires more evidence it
requires if you're a higher comparison
score and if that's if that's changed in
One Direction that will mean that the
protection rate will decrease
and the force the true detection rate
will decrease in the force detection
rate will both decrease or the other way
you could have it set so that it's it's
more it's more accepting of of of of
comparison so that
um the true detection rate will increase
but also the force detection rate will
increase
um we'll have to be a brief Focus we've
got a lot of questions
um just finally on that and then turn
back together so so so so so we find
that if the system is run at
um low thresholds and easy thresholds
that the system does start showing a
bias
against
um the the black males and females
combined sort of thing so it's so there
is there is some evidence
if if the system is operated
at certain thresholds
which I which I believe are are outside
if you could give a very brief answer to
this is there a is there scope for
improving the system
I say as a scientist
believes in Improvement in technology
there is stone for improving systems yes
thank you
and the risk of prolonging what what
kind of improvements what are the nature
of the Improvement you would see
um
everything everything or a lot of things
are a trade-offs so so you could have a
more expensive system with um with
better cameras that will be able to make
better better decisions these the
suppliers of face recognition technology
every time that there's an iteration
that tends to give an improvement in
Improvement in performance
um they have with technology that in
some circumstances already can give no
errors which is which which is which is
which is good sort of thing that's and
and then
um and this is looking at the technology
on its own there are also mitigations
which might be put in place so that so
that
um
we evaluated the algorithm on its own
but the algorithm actually does operate
in conjunction with an operator or a
police officer that's also got the the
information of the other images so so
they ask they are scope for avoiding
incorrect recognitions
that's a human level as well thank you
very much thank you Rebecca Long Bailey
and then Aaron Bell thank you Lindsay um
you mentioned earlier some of the
oversight bodies that govern the use of
Biometrics and facial recognition and
some of the regulation and guidance that
governs the area now I'm sure you'll be
aware that there's a piece of
legislation working its way through
Parliament at the moment called the data
protection and digital information Bill
and it proposes to abolish the office of
commissioner for the retention and use
of Biometrics it proposes to repeal both
the duty on the government to publish a
surveillance camera code of practice
governing the use of public space
surveillance systems by police and local
authorities and also the requirement for
a surveillance camera commissioner to
oversee it now that was so concerning
that the Biometrics commissioner himself
wrote to the committee
stating that it's worth noting that
police accountability in their use of
new technology such as facial
recognition voice pattern analysis and
other AI driven capabilities is one of
the most contentious aspects of
biometric surveillance yet remains
unaddressed either in the bill the focus
of which remains solely the regulation
of DNA and fingerprints in certain
limited circumstances or at all are you
concerned
taking a step back what I'm concerned
about is this technology is
really Innovative new and quite
difficult to get our heads around for
all of us I think as is AI as we move
forwards
the technology is cross-cutting when it
comes to Regulators so it cuts across
the Biometrics commissioner now combines
as you know the surveillance camera
commissioner it cuts across the Ico it
cuts across ehrc it cost so many
different places
I don't think that necessarily more
surveillance added on and built up and
more sorry more oversight added on and
built up is the best oversight
we run the risk of having siled
oversight
so oversight for surveillance oversight
for Biometrics oversight from data when
actually it it cuts across all of that
and currently there is guidance out
there which also sort of crosses over
and overlaps a little bit
so rather than building additional layer
upon layer of oversight at a more
superficial level
for me I think when it comes to
oversight it would be great to have
simplified oversight but with the right
questions and that's the key isn't it
the the right deeper dialect dive into
how we're using that technology to make
sure that we're behaving in the way we
should and the way we commit to in our
policy
um as a as a policing organization
there's also other oversight like hmic
to bring into it as well
do you have concerns about the
capability
be available once these offices have
been abolished and surveillance
monitoring is essentially centralized
for one of a better phrase
I um my understanding and I'm not an
expert on this bill at all from a
policing point of view my understanding
is that the role of the surveillance
camera commission will be absorbed into
the information commissioner's office
um which which from my point of view
less different bodies of surveillance
and a more simplistic approach to get to
the point of asking the right questions
is probably helpful
and on a separate issue we were
discussing the the number of images that
were held on the police National
Database have you got a figure as to how
many images are currently on the police
National Database
I don't I'm afraid I would have to write
to you if they were to come back yeah
absolutely
um just to be clear though when we're
using live facial recognition technology
the numbers on our watch list are around
in and around sort of eight eight nine
thousand I think we had just over ten
thousand for the for the coronation of
of a reasoned understanding as to why
those crime types uh or individuals are
on that watch list
um for the experiment for the work that
Dr Mansfield was talking about the watch
lists or groups were deliberately
increased to allow that to happen and
then when you look at pnd it's fast it's
much much higher numbers
and then final question on the ground in
terms of the use of this technology how
are police officers and police Personnel
trained to deploy this
so um recognizing the concerns we've
talked about today prior to every
deployment the police officers who are
going to be involved in the use of the
technology have a bespoke training
session
um and that bespoke training session is
led by one of my officers who's an
expert in in facial recognition
technology and they've run through the
kit and how it works they run through
police powers and remind them of the
need to make their own decisions at the
point of getting that match that we
talked about and we won't run through
the things to watch out for so we run
through things like demographic
differentials we run through how age
might affect things we run through how
if a trans person was to walk past the
necessity for the Privacy around that
and some of the the things they need to
be thinking about on the ground we run
through we run through do bias we talk
about it we talk about the the findings
of Dr Mansfield's report
thank you thank you very much indeed uh
Aaron Bell and then Tracy crunch thank
you um Miss chizik just going back to
what you said earlier about
proportionality and all the guidance and
the various
uh criteria operate under I mean surely
there might be instances where the model
of leaking of all the cameras would be
proportionate if there was a very
dangerous Escape criminal or someone who
just committed a serious crime would
would the met or perhaps other agencies
be able to use Facebook recognition
technology on a grand scale across the
whole capital or indeed across the whole
country if we were looking for one
individual and that was a proportionate
thing to do
foreign
it's a very difficult question in terms
of the proportionality of linking up all
cameras to find one person I think you'd
need to also weigh into that the
likelihood of actually finding that one
person by joining up all the cameras so
it comes back to what's the purpose of
what we're trying to achieve and what's
the necessity and proportionality of
that and every time that has to be the
starting point and then you make your
decision as I said earlier technically
yes that's possible
um is that not what we do already with
number plate recognition I mean are they
not linked across the whole country if
we're looking for a particular car
I guess the differences we're talking
now about a biometric which brings with
it additional sensitivities
um if I could also move on to other uses
of AI because we've spoken a lot about
facial recognition you've been very
forthcoming in your answers but what
other uses of AI are there in the Met
talking about things like uh handling
large volumes of data perhaps from
mobile phones
um looking at social media and what some
of it what's referred to as predictive
policing such as crime mapping and
individual risk assessment does the AI
use any disorder does the Met use any AI
Tools in any of these areas
the Mets at the start of experimenting
with this so we are using
um Automation in a number of areas so
robotic processing essentially
um which is logic based work only so if
x do y and if there's any anomalies
anomalies that um crop out of that then
an individual person will look at it a
number of years ago to go we did some AI
testing around crime pattern analysis
um
that was we learned a lot from it we
didn't then go ahead with it and we're
now looking at how we can incorporate
that learning and new technology because
things have moved on quite a lot
potentially to do some more trials in
the future
and of course we're aware of large
language model advances chat GPT for
example there's clearly a lot of
potential there
as long as it's approached in the right
careful and proportionate way at the
moment we're not using on a day-to-day
basis that kind of Tooling in our work I
think there is a real opportunity for
policing for handling large amounts of
data first and foremost actually
um so yes looking to the Future there's
lots of opportunity around AI I think
what we're doing at the moment is
largely around robotic processing to
save time
so there's not a there's not an
algorithmic process yet that you're
reply because I think Durham constantly
did try to create something like this
and had to well decided to stop using it
because of
concerns about the ethics of it is that
something that met looked into and have
they come to the same conclusions that
Darren constabulary did about the
ethical risks of doing this I can't I
can't comment on where Donald Constable
has got to be on knowing that they did
some experimentation in that area I
think it is something the matter
interested in if we were to go forward
with that it would involve discussions
with the various ethicists and ethics
panels so for facial recognition we
spent quite a lot of time with the
London policing ethics panel they came
up with five conditions five
recommendations for the ethical
deployments of that technology and we've
committed to follow those five
conditions those five recommendations
and all of our deployments so if we were
to go forward with another tool like
that I imagine a similar level of
Engagement both with communities and
with the ethics panel and if you did go
down this route at all there's obviously
a real question about bias
um potentially being introduced by the
data set you choose do you think it
could be at all that could reduce bias
because you take out some of the human
bias that I'm sure some of your officers
have where the intentional or
unintentional or do you think uh that's
per what was about to said earlier that
it could actually exacerbate bias if
it's being trained on the historic data
that has all that human bias in it yes
writing it'll be
it'll be able to pay really close
attention to in terms of your point
about actually removing the human bias
that's something I would say potentially
you could demonstrate with facial
recognition technology so rather than an
officer standing say at Waterloo Station
trying to remember the briefing they got
of the 10 photos that line up and then
trying to look across and see who might
be a match and using their Instinct
actually in a way the precise
racial recognition technology removes
that so you know you can flip the
argument thank you
Lindsay you're talking about deployment
earlier we've seen an increase
unfortunately in football related
disorder is there something that is
being used at um football matches other
sporting events the Met hasn't used it
in that way yet
um it's something we'll certainly keep
under review and I can see the potential
for its use around football Banning
orders for example
and am I right and thinking though that
South Wales police may have used it
recently a rugby match uh the most
recent
um deployment of South Wales police I
understand was at a concert recently
where there was Intelligence to suggest
there's going to be criminality related
to that
it were to be used
um particularly in football yeah where I
could see that it may well be you know
use for it who pays for it
would it come out the national policing
football policing budget or would it
come out of
the um the sports bodies who ends up
paying for the technology to be used
I don't know the answer to that the
technology itself is paid for
um so that doesn't cost it would be the
cost of the policing operation on the
ground and the use of live facial
recognition would only form a very small
slice of a small part of that wider
policing operation so how the policing
operation is usually paid for is the
live facial recognition technology will
be a part of that two questions too just
on the national league work obviously
um uh staying with the theme of football
do you have
um conversations with individual clubs
about the technology and how it could be
used by them
not yet
um but there's clearly a lot of
potential both around football transport
hubs airports
I mean the list of potential places for
the informed and careful use of the
technology is vast and yes that is
another option and then that opens up
opportunity doesn't it around
potentially it being owned and run by
football clubs
themselves indeed if you look in the
private sector at the moment
um
a number of shops are using it already
um so yeah
a second question as National lead my
brief mentions a tool that's been used
by Kemp police the evidence-based
investigation tool which says is an
algorithm which produces a probability
score of a crime's solvability which
informs decision making around
resourcing cases now I understand what
all those words mean on an individual
basis but could you explain what it
means in Practical terms
um no
I'm the national lead for facial
recognition
um I'm afraid Ai and tools such as that
sits elsewhere so you would really have
to speak to someone from campus I don't
know that's all
okay thank you um Dr miles will very
quickly you you actually answered my
questions around the main findings of
your um recently published research
um but I'm interested in what further
research in this area is needed
um uh you talked about improvements but
I wonder if there's any specific
research that you would like to do
there's there's there's potential for
research
exactly on face recognition and maybe it
may be delivering
um
improvements to existing capabilities
but of course npl our interests
are much broader than just face
recognition so yeah so we're working on
other areas of artificial intelligence
and um
we are involved in
volved in the um the AI standards hub
that's led by Alan Turing Institute
involves BSI
ourselves National physical laboratory
and the office for artificial
intelligence so so there are things
which are going on in terms of
developing if you like capabilities for
um
or being able to
um to evaluate to certify maybe
um actual intelligence Solutions in a
wide variety of areas
do you know what an evidence-based
investigation tool is like uh
I would say I would say no I can I said
Thank you say you can look at the words
and you can assume what what it might
mean
so so there may be something there that
say okay this is
sort of saying okay is there a
possibility of us working out which
crimes are more
solvable than others or more meaningful
but I'm not totally sure what that in
itself means
um and and I would have difficulty if I
was saying if someone said okay we've
got social system can npl evaluate it
because unless I know what it is trying
to do I cannot devise a thank you test
process thank you very much lead so we
come to Carol Monahan and then Dawn
Butler has another question and then
Stephen Metcalf
thank you chair um Lindsay can I start
with you you talked a little while ago
about how advanced the technology was
and it was difficult to keep up with
with the advances and I think we all
understand that we're not likely as mere
mortos to understand how the technology
works
but we do understand the implications of
using the technology and I think that's
really what we're trying to get our
heads around
um this morning you talked about you
talked about not wanting more oversight
and you talked about adding on layer
upon layer of oversight
um
I want to ask you a little bit about
legislation because
um
my colleague Rebecca Long Bailey has
already said we have a bill passing
through a this place at the moment which
is looking to remove the surveillance
camera commissioner and you talked about
duplication of different different
bodies now
it's my understanding that information
commissioner's office has a code of
practice for CCTV but that is an
advisory code of practice rather than a
code of practice that is an oversight
and that's quite a difference
um
where does that leave you if you if you
now have oversight by something that is
potentially advisory as opposed to a
body that is looking in great detail at
what you're doing with people's data and
how you're using it
so at the moment
um at the moment
I in I I sort of weave into our policy
the advice from both the information
commissioner's office and the
surveillance camera Commission on the
Biometrics commissioner and the other
bodies and the other thing I haven't
mentioned yet that we now have in place
for the deployment of light facial
recognition is authorized professional
practice through the College of policing
which was quite a big step forward when
that that came in
um
I I don't see it as making a huge
difference to me I'm not going to
suddenly
change how we're operating as new and it
new advice and guidance and policy comes
in regularly and we'll always review it
and ensure we've adopted where we can
what that guidance is pointing to and
it's not so much a case of not wanting
oversight or not wanting more oversight
what I really want is the right sort of
oversight to really get to the right
questions the searching questions which
will give you the assurance and do you
think an advisory code is going to give
that scrutiny and was searching
questions
the code is one thing
they then follow up on oversight and
questions that asks of the Met of how
they're applying it is another thing and
I think both of those things need to
come together cic will do that just now
and throughout the deployment of facial
recognition we've actually worked very
closely with the Ico and being on the
receiving end of some very helpful
guidance as we've been going forward you
keep talking about guidance and advice
that's different from scrutiny so I'm
trying to I'm trying to establish
whether if the Ico takes on that role
that is carried out just now by the
surveillance camera commissioner is
there going to be the same level of
scrutiny working closely can mean
guidance and advice it doesn't
necessarily mean an oversight of what's
going on and scrutinizing the practices
I don't think I can really answer that I
think that's a question for the Ico as
to how they will change in the light of
if that bill goes forward and those
recommendations they don't carry out
that role at the moment
they carry out that role in relation to
data and our data protection impact
assessment and how we handle data in
relation to facial recognition the role
of the surveillance camera commissioner
is to look at
um how we address his code of practice
and this is where it gets confusing
isn't it where there's overlap you can
see now the confusion is there
um so I in my mind if the bill goes
through and those changes are made we'll
also see a shift in how the Ico operate
to incorporate those additional measures
that's that's how I see it I don't know
if that will happen again it's a
question for the home office and for the
Ico
but to Mansfield is there anything
you're aware of that I know legislation
is maybe not your strength are there
things when you carried out your
um your investigation and produce the
report that you felt was slightly gray
in terms of legislation
not so much in terms of of
the exact
um
system we were evaluating but
um I'm involved in international
standards for uh for for Biometrics
particularly those looking at evaluation
of of performance
and in our committees we do have a piece
of work which is addressing
um the need to be able to should I audit
um
biometric systems that are used for
surveillance
and part of that is because of European
legislation and the European desire you
know in in European legislation
um the use of face recognition for
surveillance is high risk
occasion and that requires kind of
structural levels of governance
and
and what what's what will be necessary
is to have more than just I feel like a
performance
assessment
or something in perhaps in more detail
about how systems have been developed
and things like that so
um so there is work which is going on
that I'm aware of in terms of if you
like um bringing
the scientists and the evaluation
community in biometrics
um
so that there is more that can be
addressed in terms of
surveillance systems so for example the
evaluation which we which we did for for
Lindsay and the network police we were
just evaluating the algorithms and we're
evaluating the algorithms as a black box
um so we don't make any assumptions
about about the models inside and we
just we just assess it empirically by
having volunteers going through the
system we have we know what what
recognition should be made and what
recognition should not be made what what
matters should not be made because we
know the ground process to the
identities but what we don't have is we
don't have an audit of the processes in
terms of developing
in terms of developing the AI That's
being used we don't we don't see what
problems they've
they've been trying to address we don't
know what data sets they've used if
they've been using other face-to-face
data sets
um and in other areas at NPR in other
areas where we're working in AI we know
that they you know that
there can be issues in terms of whether
whether the training data set is
sufficiently adequate whether it comes
from multiple sources or not
um whether whether it is an accurately
ground truth so there are a number of
issues like that that will be applicable
to governance of of
of AI systems and AI systems using using
using face recognition thank you thank
you thank you very much uh Carol I think
Dawn had a brief um for the question
then soon thank you so there's a quick
question
um Lindsay sorry in response to uh Tracy
you said that you've never deployed LFR
at a football match
um how do you decide where you deploy at
LFR
so it's based on an intelligence case
um so if if there's
and it's based on intelligence case and
it's part of a wider policing operation
so for example and I talked a little bit
about Camden which was the last
of deployments we did there was high
levels of violent robbery there is and
still is a sort of ongoing gang issues
in the area
um there was the shooting at Houston at
the church some of you remember in
January this year and that and a number
of other issues
pointed towards
um it being a good location as part of a
wider policing operation going on at the
time
um to deploy facial recognition in that
area so there is a requirement to do so
the other thing I didn't mention was
violence against women and girls there's
a nighttime economy there um and there's
some issues around events against
women's and girls related to that
nighttime economy so none of that
applies to football no
no it doesn't it
was different for the
um for the combination and the the use
case the requirement there primary
requirement was to protect Public Safety
so if fixated individuals if there's
intelligence that fixated individuals
we're going to be at the coronation and
we had that image that was a good use
case for that now if we're already
deploying the technology for that reason
and we have
um other people wanted on court warrants
or wanted for other offenses who those
intelligence suggest are going to be in
the sort of broad area at the time we
can put those on the watch list again as
well that's came up in the bridges
judgment and appeal um and that's why
it's against women and girls increases
uh after football matches during
football matches
um so I am surprised that that it's
never been deployed at a football match
how many times has it been deployed at
nightinghill carnival once
once and that was in the very early days
of us learning to use the technology
um and it wasn't a very successful
deployment and what we learned from that
was the the sheer number of faces the
density of the crowd made it very
difficult for the technology to operate
there was just too many it was two pack
there's too many faces so we'll take
that learning and and and use it going
forwards so how does that apply then to
Wembley way you know with what 60 000
plus you know where where does it get to
a point where there are too many people
for it to be deployed I mean this comes
down to Wrecking in advance where we're
going to deploy using previous knowledge
of other events and looking at the best
place for that technology so I don't
know Wembley unfortunately I don't know
Wembley way but I'm not necessarily
saying that's where we deploy the kit it
there's a number of places in and around
football where it could be deployed and
as part of the planning for that event
the the recess would be important plus
learning that I've just talked about and
other learning with people pick up along
the way so after every deployment we
consider what we've learned from it and
we use that to go forward that this is
early days so absolutely right on Vogue
and absolutely right on football and
it's a really interesting point that
I'll take forward and think about
um but this is something we're going to
have to build on as we go forwards okay
uh can we have finally to see the makeup
thank you very much good morning
um
I think from your view this is a really
useful tool
um I'm slightly puzzled why uh Dr
Mansfield described it as a high risk
when you say it's so very accurate can
you just clarify I said the European
commissioner right declare that is it
that it's home it counts as a high risk
okay
um and would you agree with that just
briefly I wanted to keep this quite
tight because we have one out of time
not haunted
not necessarily in the worst cases I
mean you can imagine cases that yes I
will classify it as being high risk and
in other cases I perhaps wouldn't but if
it's accurate how can it be high risk
if it's just an accurate tool that
identifies people who are on a watch
list how is it high risk
it's um it's
it's okay
this is not this this this is not my
classification no okay fair enough I
think I suppose what I'm trying to get
to it is
system doing anything more than a
anything more than at a significantly
larger scale than a well-trained
particularly observant particularly uh
um experienced officer might be able to
do
sitting at a good Vantage Point within a
crowd an officer would never be able to
do what that kid does at scale at scale
so but could it well I'm saying if you
had made a superhuman officer is it
doing anything more than that other than
identifying people so no it's not but an
officer could never remember Ten
Thousand Faces and identified him in a
crowd so but it
imagine he could for a moment it would
be extraordinary but that's all it's
doing it's not identifying people
outside of a list of people who you've
put on a watch list right it only takes
us two so why is not everyone on the
Mets police's watch list on the watch
list that you deploy
when you deploy the technology
so
we
went a lot from the bridges judgment and
the bridges appeal
in the in in those in those two reviews
appeal and the review
um
there were questions asked around two
deployments around specifically The Who
and the where the who related to the
watch list
so our policy and the authorized
professional practice which the College
of policing now have have taken their
learning from what came out of bridges
because there's not a lot out there to
go on
um and we need to have
a reason for having people on a watch
list it can't just be everybody but
you've got to this back to my difference
between the technology and an officer
the Met maintain a database of people
they would like to interview discuss
potential why are all those people not
on the list when the technology is
deployed because if an officer could
remember those tens of thousands that
would be perfectly acceptable for them
to go up to someone and say I think I
would like to have a word with you and
discuss this further it was back to
necessity and proportionality the people
on
list for
a facial Wrecking technology there needs
to be some
likelihood of them being in the area
where those cameras are deployed at the
time so if I'm deploying cameras in
Camden now will be a it's a transport
Hub that's trained this tube and the
neighboring boroughs there's there's
evidence of people traveling across
London to go to Camden
if if there's someone from Newcastle say
I wouldn't have them on that watch list
no but is that I understand your
comments across London but still some
thought needs to go into that watch list
to look at the likelihood of people
being on there actually having a chance
why because you think the accuracy of
the technology would start to falter if
you may had too many people on the list
not at all not at all the technology can
deal with it it's to do it so it was
this just a it's to do with the law and
the British judgment right so and was
that a sticking plaster
those judgments were those were those to
placate those who oppose the technology
or was there a real operational reason
for this because back to the comparison
between the technology and a very well
trained experienced super memory officer
is it it's not doing anything more than
doing identifying those who are
potential suspects I don't think a
judicial review
s in that manner as either a stick
judicial review examiners the facts at
the time which the facts of two very
specific deployments
so
um
it is limited in its use it has a a list
that's deleted after 24 hours
again but you don't delete the main list
you don't ask officers to forget who
they're looking for
um why has it only been deployed in
Camden and Islington across London you
think you said it's been deployed six
times three of which I'm talking about
this year
but if it's such a good tool why is it
not more readily and rapidly
talked about the journey we're on at the
moment right you know it's taken a lot
of work to get us here in the right way
now we have the findings of Dr
Mansfield's report that's really helpful
and I think we do intend to use it more
often in future in the right way with
the right safeguards in place
um would you like to change some of
those judgments that that have
been put in place previously that
restrict how this is used
so
the thing I
and what we're allowed to operate under
currently we operate under common law
with the patchwork quilt of different
laws like human rights act the apologies
act data protection act under underneath
that and then we have College of
policing authorized professional
practice underneath that which was a
brilliant step forward and really
helpful for police who want to use the
technology
when it comes to the law and AI I think
regulating each individual technology is
probably not the way forward because the
law takes a long time to make doesn't it
and by the time the law is made and gone
through the technology will have changed
and it'll be out of date we see that a
little bit with
um with the investigatory Powers Act for
example
so in order for law to keep Pace with AI
and fast changing technology I think
broado is probably better
but yes I can see a future where the law
will need to change to keep Pace with a
whole range of AI opportunity out there
and I guess that's what you're here to
yes and that is my final point is about
where the future lies I suppose what I'm
asking you to take a view on is are we
regulating this technology in a
different way
because it's got the word technology in
it rather than what it actually does the
way we regulate the way an officer May
behave
and can you see that changing in the
future and would you like to see it
change in the future and can you see any
other ways well what in Future Would you
envisage for the use of AI and this sort
of facial technology
so I think I
um as part of the Assurance measures for
the public along with our transparency
and our engagement and everything else
so I think it's important
um I think it's important to do it
in the right way with the right
questions that get to the point of how
we're using the tech and then
separate actually officer behavior and
how they go about their day-to-day
policing duties we have oversight from
hmic we have oversight from Mopac and
from a number of other places
I separate those out in my own mind
because to bring them together will be
quite difficult wouldn't it it gets even
more confusing so in terms of the the AI
I guess what I would like is streamlined
um clear
advice
around oversight and what's expected
um asking asking the right questions
and not sort of taking where we are now
and just building it up and up and up it
kind of needs it needs something which
is coordinated and streamlined
I'm just final part I did say that was
my final point but
um
do you think that their the technology
can potentially be rolled out
across an entire city if the accuracy is
as good as it says is there any reason
to restrict how widely it is used does
it do anything more does it present any
more of a threat than an officer does
I don't believe
it presents
any more threat I don't even like that
terminology
risk I don't know I don't know what the
right word I'm not I don't mean the
opposite yeah I know what you mean um so
so technically it's feasible
um
the future is going to see the use of
facial recognition more and more in the
private sphere is going to see the use
of facial recognition potentially by
criminals as they try and identify
undercover offices for example and
another nefarious activity so it feels
right to me that the police moves with
the times looks at technology in a
careful way and looks how we can make
the best of it
um but at the same time we police by
consent and there's a big part of this
which is public consent to our use of
that technology now we did some um there
was some uh polling a number of years
ago we need to renew the polling polling
a number of years ago by a variety of
different organizations show between I
think it was 70 and 85 of the public was
supportive of the youth Police use of
live facial recognition technology but
of course that depends on the question
asked and I think there's some there's
some really interesting work that can be
done around that so that we can
understand and bring the public with us
ultimately it comes down to a privacy
versus security debate doesn't it
personally I am relaxed about my image
my Biometrics being momentarily taken
compared against the watch list
pixelated in the back of the van so that
people can't see my face and and if that
helps prevent crime and stops a wanted
offender being on the streets I'm fine
with that I understand that everybody's
in that position and that privacy and
security debate I can contribute to it
from the police world but it's not for
me to lead it
finally uh Catherine one last question
very briefly I just I think so much of
the Techno use of technology is about
the application by humans of it
um and so I just wanted to return back
to how the faces get into the system
that they're being looked for and what
operational oversight there is there
because we've had some concerning uh
incidents in the past especially around
Vogue and I'm wondering whether if
somebody is looking for his
ex-girlfriend and happens to be the man
in the van whether he can put that face
in or whether there is a robust
framework to make sure that the faces
the system is searching for is only
people with a reasonable evidence base
yeah okay
um so is reassurance when one of these
operations is put together there's an
authorization process the authorization
and there's a form filled out with the
intelligence case with the watch list
categories with different levels of
intrusion signed off at different levels
depending on what it is so we recognize
nice for example children under 18s
people with disabilities and we talk
briefly about trans people earlier
they're examples of areas of extra
sensitivity where extra thought needs to
be given well I'm probably confident in
that you're very robust in the official
list that you're searching for it's who
is checking that I don't know Maureen
who's actually loading up the system to
look he's only looking for what you
think she's looking for that that
process I described to you signed off by
a superintendent if additional images
came in for example we were deploying
and then suddenly there was an alert and
there was a there's a wanted offender on
the street and we needed to get it
quickly into the system that would also
have to go through either the
superintendent who's the authorizing
officer for the operation or the gold
Commander who's actually overseeing
that operation on that day it may be
more than the same okay so the
superintendence is in effect in charge
of monitoring the fact that only only
the official list is being searched yes
right and that requires a certain level
of technological capability from that
individual
the superintendent themselves won't
personally be doing that uploading work
that will be taken undertaken by an
engineer yeah and it's the engineer fine
it's the end the super Pretenders has
oversight and responsibility for that
yeah perhaps
verify the checking process afterwards
unconscious time yeah thank you
um as is evidence we have lots of
questions and probably some more that
actually we'd like to follow up in uh in
writing yeah with you both if we may but
um thank you very much you've been very
comprehensive and uh wide-ranging in
your answers very grateful to Lindsay
Chadwick and Dr Tony Mansfield for
reference this morning we're now going
to turn to our next uh panel of
witnesses a pair of witnesses I'd like
to invite to the table uh Michael Bert
whistle
who is the associate director for AI and
data law and policy at the Ada Lovelace
Institute
and joining
Mr Burke was at the table is Dr Marion
Oswald of the Alan Turing Institute who
is a lawyer as well as an academic who
researches the interaction between law
and digital technology at Human Rights
ethics and the use of data within
policing and intelligence agencies and
Dr Oswald also chairs the West Midlands
police and crime commissioner and West
Midlands police data Ethics Committee
thank you very much indeed both of you
for coming and thanks for being here for
the previous session you've heard some
of the uh the questions and the scrutiny
that has been on our minds perhaps I can
turn to Mr burst Bristol first and just
give the committee your assessment of I
think the question that ran through the
previous panel which is can
algorithms and AI in this case applied
to facial recognition be safely used in
policing would you say
thank you chair and thank you to the
committee for having me today
um I think there are um
two broad classes of risks that are
associated with
um use of Biometrics in in policing
um that we've heard today about the
accuracy of those systems the
differential accuracy of those systems
um and the sort of second class around
um the power of uh facial recognition
systems biometric systems to undermine
Democratic rights and freedoms such as
privacy
um we think that without a proper
regulatory framework
um there isn't a guarantee that facial
recognition systems deployed by police
meet will meet reasonable standards of
accuracy or that their use will remain
proportionate to the risks presented by
them
um in July 2019 this committee
um called for an independent review of
the options for the use and retention of
biometric data and the Ada Lovelace
Institute decided to respond to that
call in last year published a report
that represents the culmination of a
three-year program of work on Biometrics
governance that included public
engagement research on attitudes towards
biometric Technologies both via
nationally representative survey and Via
a Citizens Biometrics Council and an
independent legal review by Matthew
Ryder KC
that report made some urgent
recommendations about the sort of
sufficient legal framework that we need
to govern these Technologies both in the
public and the private sector okay can
can I just um uh ask him about you we're
talking about facial recognition but
there's a specific AI Dimension to it is
is there a specific concern about the
use of artificial intelligence and
machine learning uh with facial
recognition Technologies or other
concerns of the edel of lace institute
around facial recognition as it were
sort of without
the AI dimension
so uh there's sort of two parts to that
question I think
um our concerns as articulated in the
countermeasures report last year uh
uh Center on the use of biometric data
as a unique a uniquely personal data
type
um which is then and second part
often used now in combination
increasingly with artificial
intelligence Technologies not only to
infer identity about people but also to
identify
um infer other characteristics now that
could be a protected characteristic but
it also could be an internal State
such as whether you're paying attention
what emotion you're feeling whether you
have violent intent and make claims
about those sorts of predictions so it's
the combination of both biometric data
and the applications that it is
increasingly being used for it doesn't
that um that combination actually
supplies some of the answers to the
earlier concerns about
facial recognition so that we know that
human beings are prone to to biases
if it's a human being that is looking
out for people to question and to detain
they consciously or unconsciously may be
biased in the types of people that they
they stop and search if you have ai that
is providing the filter that has
that is not subject to to those same
human biases does that not inject a
greater rigor into the selection
of images for people to be questioned
there is a often cited ambition for that
to be the eventual place that these
Technologies are are capable of doing
but it is
um not the case in terms of typically
the accuracy of of these systems bias as
identified in two CDI
um AI barometer reports is one of the
highest risks of these systems so in
fact the risk currently goes the other
way towards entrenchment of potential
discrimination by these systems and it's
also not the practice of how that is
used
the police do use a human in the loop
currently and even under those
circumstances the court of appeal held
and the bridges judgment that the uh the
use of facial recognition was not
according to the law what do you make of
the uh the report of the national
physical laboratory we've heard from Dr
Mansfield that that looked at the
deployment by the Metropolitan Police
some of it experimental and concluded
that there was there was no significant
evidence of bias in terms of demographic
groups
so while I think it's laudable for the
police forces to have submitted their
systems um to this kind of scrutiny that
firstly there is no clear legal
requirement for police forces to test or
demonstrate the accuracy of facial
recognition in this way and this is a
snapshot of a single version of a single
system set to a very particular setting
and the results can't be generalized to
other systems or versions so or
variations in deployment conditions so
poor lighting or weather video
compression lower quality watch list
image watch list images which are all
covered in 9.7 of that report as areas
for further research okay let me take
some questions from colleagues starting
with Aaron Bell then Rebecca Long Bailey
thank you chair um because I turned to
Dr Oswald as well
um what do you see as the main risks
associated with AI in the policing and
security context and are are they being
mitigated or how could they be mitigated
if they're not
for the invitation to speak today I
suppose it might be just worth briefly
summarizing what the what the AI that
being used by the police is
um
I think we can probably narrow them down
into three categories or three or four
categories firstly tools that are really
there for recording and organizing data
secondly data analytics so to try and
create insights Trends connections
between people
using things like natural language
processing and network analysis and then
quite importantly risk prediction which
I think is where the solvability
algorithm would come in so trying to
predict future happenings or future
risks based based on past data either
individuals or situations so that that's
what the solvability algorithm basically
is and then tools to identify people as
as you've been discussing this morning
um
I mean I think there's definitely some
potential around these these tools and
we've certainly seen some of these tools
having this potential within the West
Midlands committee
but
um
they're they're I think within policing
there's actually quite limited use of
these tools and you might be surprised
the number of forces still using Excel
spreadsheets and not the more
sophisticated methods
um and I think this is down to the issue
around data Basics the fact that uh data
is not necessarily held in consistent
format
um the the update for the police
national computer is delayed
um it's not now to incorporate the
intelligence records in the police
National Database and so a number of
bigger forces have actually invested
their own time and money in in separate
databases we heard from Lindsay about
their investment in a a different system
for photographs so all all data isn't
really joined up it's not necessarily
consistent and so that that in itself
creates a risk
and and I think we also don't have a
complete picture of what forces are
doing with AI machine learning because
there is that there's no Central public
record or database so we only know from
things like local knowledge freedom and
information requests House of Lords
reports that sort of thing
um in terms of the risks
um there is really no consistent or
agreed ethical scientific evaluation
transparency or quality standards around
the technology to decide whether it's
any good for a particular policing
purpose
um
so each police force is really left to
decide whether to develop or deploy or
buy Technologies and I think as we heard
in the previous session that police
forces are asking for more consistent
and overarching guidance around this
we also continue to see many examples of
AI sometimes built by commercial
providers promoted for criminal justice
purposes such as AI weapons detection or
detecting violent behavior on trains
without any independent validation or
checking of whether those claims are
valid and and that's particularly
concerning in that question can we be
briefly you've given written evidence so
we're keen to have um sort of oral
exchanges so we take as read the the
evidence that you've submitted Aaron
thank you Chad um you set out some of
those those risks there then that um
do you think any police forces are in a
position to evaluate what you know these
tools that they're being using let's
leave facial recognition to one side for
a minute because we've talked a lot
about it already all this other stuff
actually is potentially it might be more
concerning because we don't know about
the efficacy of it we haven't had the
sort of tests that the national physical
laboratory have done and basically
forces are experiments you know one of
the advantages of having lots of forces
is that you can try things out in
different areas but are they in any
position to evaluate whether it's any
good
I think some forces are because they
have internal expertise to do that or
they have bodies that they can go to
Independent advisors that they can go
get that sort of a rise from other small
forces may be in a much more uh limiting
position in that respect and so this is
why there is such an importance for for
the for the national guidance national
standards to be set and for the the
standards to relate to the coercive
powers that the police have and the
technology is not there on its own it's
related to the stop and search the
arrest the investigatory powers that the
police are deploying and so the guidance
really need to very clearly relate to
that and do you think all these forces
are aware of the ethical risks involved
and do you think they are all aware of
the need to keep as the phrase goes the
human in the loop when they are trying
trying these things out
I think there's definitely an awareness
of that human in the loop concept you
know concept what that means though is
quite difficult I mean in facial
recognition terms
um we heard about how officers are
giving training about the deployment of
facial recognition but
um it's very difficult when you're
presented with a match to decide what to
do with it unless you really understand
the settings of the system what the
uncertainties might be what the risks
are for errors and biases
in the report that the npl issued it's
very significant that the figures around
ethnic disparities are based around a
particular face matched setting if you
look at a setting of 0.56
you will see that
the the number of people falsely
identified of the 33 that were falsely
identified 22 of those were black
so at settings that are lower than the
recommended settings ethnic disparities
will occur and it's important for the
police to be aware of that so that they
can deploy those Technologies in an
appropriate manner thank you if I could
just go back to you Mr Burt whistle on
the non-facial recognition stuff what
concerns do you have about the use of AI
uh by policing say predictive policing
or data analytics and so on uh other
examples where it's working well at the
moment you're comfortable with or is it
again something that you're concerned
about in the same way that you are with
facial recognition technology
so
Ado Loveless Institute hasn't published
research more broadly on policing use of
Technology it's focused on Biometrics
I can speak to the uh the proposals in
the AI white paper
which
look to existing Regulators existing
regulation to govern those Technologies
so if we're thinking about whether the
measures are going to be there to to to
[Music]
bring in those accuracy standards or or
to
um
provide the scrutiny that
um that we've been talking about
[Music]
um
that the the white paper doesn't add
anything to that picture other than to
provide existing Regulators with a set
of principles and to provide them with
some Central coordination
um and and some other risk functions
however the the House of Lords report
last year looking at this identified I
think 30 different uh bodies responsible
for looking at policing use of
technology and said it's very difficult
to build up a complete picture and so
it's not clear
um how the the white paper proposes to
improve governance in such diffusely
regulated contexts like policing thank
you very much indeed Rebecca Long Bailey
you and Dr Oswald can you bring outline
what what some police forces are doing
to increase transparency around the use
of AI and data such as the committee
that you chair in the West Midlands
thank you the committee
was set up by West Midlands police in
the West Midlands PCC in 2019 to sit
alongside the data analytics work that
the force has been doing it's got its
own data lab and its own employed data
scientists and it was recognized that
created new risks and new challenges so
we are a voluntary body made up of
independent volunteers from all sorts of
different backgrounds law ethics
computer science
medical expert people who have knowledge
of the the interests of victims and we
take a a rolling approach to looking at
projects from from the beginning sort of
idea stage to operational rollouts if
that happens and our role is to give
pragmatic advice to the chief Council
and the PCC and their representatives
around the
um the deployment of Technology
asking them to think about
how how these these Technologies might
be deployed operationally what
consequences might occur all the minutes
and papers are transparent and so it is
possible through that process to find
out a lot about the sort of projects
that police are considering in the sort
of data that is being used I think
another really key initiative is the the
government's algorithmic transparency
recording standard which has recently
been rolled out and a number of police
forces have contributed to the pilot of
that and demonstrated how by engaging
more information could be provided to
the public around technology being used
within police forces some research I did
also demonstrated that the police think
that it could be a really useful
initiative to help them learn from each
other because they don't necessarily
know what other forces are doing and
what's been successful what hasn't
by further engaging in that initiative
and potentially becoming
even a mandatory process that could has
the potential to improve quality within
policing technology and do you think it
should be a mandatory process across all
forces
my personal view is yes there seems to
be no reason why it can't be there are
there are initiatives that you could put
in place to protect sensitive
information and protect sensitive trade
craft and ensure those appropriate
exemptions but from from the research
I've done I think it could be a really
positive step
and Michael do you think that the
efforts that have just been outlined by
Dr Oswald are sufficient to address
concerns that have been raised
um about these tools and if not what
more needs to be done what would you
like to see
so I think they would complement our
proposals around comprehensive
Biometrics governance
I think there is a question about
investment to scale the
um
the sort of the safeguards and the
mechanisms that Marion's described would
would take considerable investment to
roll that out on a national scale but I
think that would be a positive thing and
I'd very much Echo the endorsement of
the algorithmic transparency recording
standard and the desire for it as it
matures to
um for there to be a mechanism for it to
be made mandatory
thank you very much I'm going to go to
Carol Monahan now thank you chair um my
cookie just start with you and you've
already highlighted the link between AI
governs and data protection what are
your thoughts or um on the new data
protection and digital information bill
that we're dealing with at the moment
you mean specifically with reference to
policing or more broadly
um you could start with policing yeah
um so so I think
um
the dpdi bill with respect to
governance of Technology by by police
and particularly Biometrics does make
the picture worse as we've heard the
abolition of the Biometrics commission
and the surveillance camera commissioner
which obviously by one individual at the
moment but the code as well
um are are problematic
um as we've heard the commissioners
have written to the bill committee
um stating that not all of those
functions are being transferred in in
his view to the Ico or ipco
um and that those are some uh some very
important
um uh sort of
um Provisions around scrutiny and and
oversights I think it's also notable
that
um when we're looking at something like
Bridges and the way that the law
currently Works
um the
the sort of the the
um
one of the grounds on which facial
recognition there failed to um to be
lawful was on this question of whether
it was done in accordance with the law
which when you sort of drilled down into
the legal technicalities of it is saying
is there a sufficient legal framework
there and the surveillance camera code
was a core part of of that legal
framework that was examined and even
with that being in place it was seen as
um as being an insufficient framework to
be in accordance with the law so that
that element seems to be being taken
away which in our view
um reduces probably the confidence with
which these these Technologies can be
used in in policing with the
um
uh the peace of mind that they are
lawful we heard from a previous witness
about this layer upon layer of oversight
um and duplication
do you see the current system is having
duplication
um do you see the bill
um improving this in terms of of users
and
um keepers of personal information
um
I mean I think the um the claim that it
simplifies the regulatory landscape
um may be true in the sense that there
will be fewer actors in it but that
doesn't mean that there will be more
regulatory clarity
for users of that technology
um and as I've said that the you know
the the
um the removal of the surveillance
camera code is one such thing the
proposal that we've made in terms of
comprehensive comprehensive Biometrics
regulation would centralize a lot of
those functions within a specific
regulatory function within the Ico that
would have specific responsibility for a
lot of the
um the sort of the safeguards that
Marion has described so um things like
publishing a register of public sector
use requiring biometric Technologies to
meet scientifically based standards and
having a role in assessing the proper
proportionality of those being used and
having those all happening in one place
I think would would be a simplification
and provide that that sort of
appropriate oversight thank you talk to
us
I'd agree that uh simplification doesn't
necessarily mean the clarity and
certainly in the policing sector I think
we need much more clarity as to where
the responsibility really lies we've got
lots of bodies uh with fingers in the
pie but not necessarily anyone
responsible for the overall cooking of
the pie so I think I think that's
required here
do you see I mean
are we getting the right balance between
protection of personal data and
legitimate use of of biometric
information
I think it really depends on on the
context and that's why the regulatory
structure needs to be very focused on
how police are using data and the
different ways that AI can be deployed
sometimes it's deployed in respect of
you know coercive coercive Powers stop
and search arrest but sometimes it's
being deployed in the investigation
stage and the intelligence stage which
brings on all sorts of different
considerations so any regulator needs to
understand that and be able to set rules
around those different
processes and different stages
if I can add to that I think
um adding to the points made earlier
about
um uh sufficient future proofing and
flexibility of of the law the way that
you achieve that is by having empowered
uh regulatory institutions that are
properly resourced and that is a concern
both with Biometrics but also generally
with the um the proposals in the white
paper do you think sorry I was going to
finish but just do you think I mean
we're getting rid of two offices and
shopping it all into the Ico
um
is this is this an attempt to save money
to make what what is it really trying to
do
I can't comment on the
um the sort of the the rationale for
doing that
um I think that
the
importance of these Technologies and the
benefits of these Technologies could be
huge and if we want to secure them we
need public trust we need those
Technologies to be trustworthy and that
is worth investing regulatory capability
in
thanks very much um Catherine what's
next thank you chair um Dr Charles well
thanks for coming
um we thought the government's got a an
AI white paper out at the moment so I
perhaps just want to kind of pivot to
what's in that and what we do for the
future so you've highlighted in your
submission the need for a context
specific nuanced approach and I just
wonder if you could perhaps Define that
a bit better for us
and cross-reference it to the
government's uh white paper that does
the proposals within the white paper
achieve you know meet what you seek to
achieve
of course yes
I'm definitely in favor an approach that
addresses how AI is being used in the
policing sector which is what I mean by
context-specific approach
um and really bringing in the key
principles of criminal justice
but I'm not in favor of relying only on
High level principles and hoping that
everyone would be able to interpret
those
and what they mean particularly in
really high stakes environments like
policing so
I think that it's the the white paper is
a Goods First Step but we will need to
interpret those principles and find out
what they re what do they really what
does transparency really mean for
policing and AI what does explainability
really mean what does a police officer
need to know when they are using a
facial recognition tool for example or
what do they need to know when they're
using a solvability algorithm and those
those things are not necessarily the
same
um for each each tool
um
so so I think without that we
potentially will continue to see police
forces deploying and rolling out
different Tools in in a very
individualized way without that
consistency of approach
for instance of the type the next level
of detail under the white paper that
you'd like to see in this context
sure well if if we take say a tool that
um is perhaps trying to build
connections between individuals to
identify new members of a organized
crime gang for example
you might build that data based on
intelligence
information
or things like non-crime data
this might be them all being at the same
bus stop or something yeah exactly or
you know hanging around on the same
street or being seen in the same
vicinity or having a link via a phone
number or that type of thing
um the issue with intelligence is it's
not uh it doesn't necessarily mean
something bad or something good it's
just a piece of information that you
have to interpret if you then try and
put it into a data analytics tool what
happens is it tends to become either bad
or good and the Nuance of it disappears
and you could end up with quite a
misleading output that says just because
somebody's on this street therefore they
are bad and they are linked with these
other bad people so it's that sort of
detail that really needs to be thought
about before these tools are built so
you understand the data input and what
it really is
and then you build the tool
appropriately so that you when you get
the output you really know how to use it
you don't necessarily rely on it
inappropriately yeah so if I if I just
make play that back make sure I
understand you the white paper the
principles in the white paper are you're
comfortable with it's the mix it's the
Practical translation of those
principles into a number of fields that
is the area of Direction yeah yeah I
think it's that you know the expert
knowledge that you need to do that so
it's really important here as someone
that started my career helping people
get off leather bound ledgers and in his
computers it's it's that classic
transition of shall we say poo in and
poo out perhaps yeah
um thank you for that Michael if I can
switch to you
um again just understanding where we are
with the government's AI white paper
you're calling for a clear governance
framework so that would appear to be a a
more broad-reaching thing that's within
the government's white paper at the
moment you know will it help set the
scene for such a framework is it
actually going to deliver that framework
where what's your take on the pet work
paper
so to be clear our call for
um Biometrics governance is
um uh is sort of complementary I think
to probably what's what's in the white
paper the white paper looks at existing
regulation we're saying that governance
does not exist for Biometrics currently
and won't be added by the white paper so
that needs to sort of happen separately
um looking at the white paper more
broadly I think there are a lot of
advantages to the context-specific
approach it sets out I think the real
tests for it are going to be around
implementation
um and if you'll forgive the
alliteration you've sort of got three
lenses or tests that we're going to be
looking at it through and talking about
publicly soon one is around coverage so
there are some domains where you don't
have as domain-specific regulator like
employment and Recruitment
and so it's not clear who's going to be
responsible for making sure use cases in
that sector Accord with the principles
as I've said that's also problem for
diffusely regulated sectors it's not
just policing education might be another
way you've got sort of different
Regulators looking at different bits of
the system but not necessarily overall
oversight
um the second sort of test is around
capability institutional capability so
um do Regulators have the resources and
the powers that they need in order to
deliver on those principles
um and there are some I think very
significant questions there about the
amount of resourcing needed to
appropriately govern a general purpose
technology like Ai and then the third
one is criticality so will we have
enough action on urgent risks and this
is where the question about general
purpose AI like chap GPT comes in and
whether we need a faster response to
that ahead of the implementation window
of over a year that the government set
out yeah understood
the basic principles there's nothing is
there anything missing apart from
perhaps more detail on the
implementation perhaps if either of you
have looked at that paper and thought
well I really think it should have had
that in it
um privacy isn't in it but I think the
um the the team behind the white paper
have taken the view that that is already
fairly comprehensively covered by data
Protection Law
um
there are
um sort of uh questions not about the
sort of the high level principles but
whether or not all of the sort of
instructions to Regulators that these
principles represent will necessarily be
deliverable by those Regulators under
their existing powers and remits yeah
don't tell us what
the white paper talks a lot about
focusing on use and not not on the
technology which I think is is fair
enough up to a certain point but I think
there are certain Technologies or um
such implementations where we do have to
look at the tech itself such as emotion
AI which comes from a very dubious
scientific background you know similar
to the polygraph
um you know the science we all love a
bit of phrenology yeah scientific
validity very dubious there and the Ico
said that so at some points we do have
to say do we just not want to use these
especially in criminal justice where you
know serious consequences can occur
right so a non-low evidence-based or no
evidence-based technologies that the the
ability to exclude potentially could be
included in the future white paper yes
yeah I understood thank you Josh
Catherine Ernest Stephen Metcalf and the
finally grown Stringer
um thank you
um
Michael if I may um just a quick
question about a statement that the Ada
lovelos
um
Institute made which was around the use
of Standards to create an AI governance
framework
or their importance I just wondered if
you could explain exactly what that
means and where you think the benefits
would be
cool so I think standards standards are
going to have a very important role in
any potential regulatory regime for AI
so there's just before we go on Define
what you mean by standards because I
think there was always a danger everyone
has a different
or so so I think we're referring to
process standards technical standards um
the sorts of things that standard
setting bodies such as the BSI in the UK
um ISO IEEE those sorts of bodies set
and using those
um as ways of helping to govern and
standardize the way in which AI is
developed
um sort of as a process so you sort of
have horizontal and process standards
and you can also have vertical standards
which are for example used very commonly
in medical devices regulation
okay thank you and now about how you
think this will work within AI the what
sort of standards would you like to
introduce
or do you think would work
so
um I think the white paper sets out
um uh a very helpful vision of the role
of standards and also Assurance
techniques which are things like
um audit for example
that
will help support the way that different
actors in the ecosystem working with AI
can help know what to do is right and
also from a regulatory perspective
um Regulators are able to use those
potentially to help understand whether
or not companies look like they are
doing the right sorts of things to make
sure that you get the right outcomes
from AI development I think there are
sort of three interesting questions
around
um uh the use of standards for AI the
first is who gets to participate in
setting them we are doing a lot of work
in Europe at the moment around the fact
that these are typically set largely by
industry
um and there is uh perhaps a a degree of
Industry capture in in
um who gets to set them secondly there's
a question about regulator maturity some
Regulators are really well equipped to
use them and use them as standard some
uh very much less so but they could be a
really useful tool for regulators and
lastly there's a question of the
international picture and
um uh you know the the the US and
Brussels are obviously taking a very
active interest in
um uh the standards that will support
the development of AI and
um the UK to some extent
um will be
[Music]
um
competing for influence over what those
standards become
and have you actually said made any
suggestion about what those standards
should be
um practical steps that you know we
could log and
I I don't think we've we've specified
standards I think we have specified for
example within Biometrics governance a
role for
um that function to set those standards
or or to identify those standards I mean
those standards are typically developed
by those standard setting organizations
so it's not um you know we would want to
see them we would want to see the
principles within the white paper
supported by those standards but that I
believe is working trained within
government okay and has anyone that
you're aware of
um been as bold to make any suggestions
about what standards AI should be
governed against
uh yes yes I mean there's lots of active
work and the UK has a sort of set up a
standards Hub that is working with
International Partners in in sort of
working out which are most appropriate
and I believe there is work going
ongoing within government to understand
specifically which sets of Standards can
support the individual principles okay
okay that's fine thank you very much
news and finally Graham Stringer
the UK election results
diverging
from the EU
and regular regulatory governance
framework for AI is it important I mean
should the future of the governance of
AI
the is it better as an international
Global level or is it better of each
country goes its own way
I think
um
they had a Lovelace Institute supports
interoperability of these AI
Technologies that's going to be very
important for ensuring that the the
benefits of them are distributed
equitably and that they support trade
between nations I think there's a
question about which bits of it you
govern at what level so there is
potentially a role at the international
level to look particularly at the
urgency surrounding general purpose AI
systems or Foundation models as they're
sometimes called
um and looking at some of the emerging
capabilities that those systems have and
understanding whether an international
approach is going to be the most
effective at mitigating those quite
wide-ranging risks from very powerful
systems but I think it's also right to
have a context-specific approach for our
country for more detailed applications
as Marin and I have already spoken to
if I could add I think it's
important that we take accounts in the
criminal justice context of those
applications at the EU level that have
been identified at the most high risk
because you know that will have
implications for trade and and criminal
justice cooperation
Etc
um how we deal with those ourselves I
think we need to make a decision on
and if you could have
one recommendation that the government
would agree to
Implement uh on its future
House of